voilà c'était les petites traînes de
Maurepas et autour de cette table pour
continuer à reparler sport avec que des
messieurs
pour changer tout d'abord on va parler
des Kiden mais avec avec Monsieur Pons
Francis pense qui est le président de
l'ASPTT Yvelines Peugeot alors les Kiden
juste pour remettre dans le contexte et
ce marathon en relais organiser donc
dimanche prochain sur la base de loisirs
de Saint-Quentin-en-Yvelines c'est ça
c'est ça c'est sa 4e édition et on
espère encore un gros succès alors en
quoi ça consiste l'équilaine le marathon
en équipe qu'est-ce que ça veut dire bah
en fait c'est une très vieille course
qui date de 1917 qui a eu lieu au Japon
et qui a s'est déroulé en trois jours
pour relier la ville de Tokyo plus
exactement l'ancienne capitale à la
nouvelle capitale de Tokyo c'est pour ça
que Ekiden
mais beaucoup de gens se posent la
question en fait c'est une contraction
de deux mots au niveau du japonais qui
veut dire et transmettre puisqu'en fait
c'était un système de relais entre
différentes gares qui permettaient
d'amener des messages donc très
anciennez
l'agglomération de 50 ans Yvelines vous
êtes les seuls à organiser ce genre de
Marathon sur le département des Yvelines
oui et sur l'Île-de-France dans le
concept réel de l'equidia nous sommes
les seuls aussi puisqu'il y a d'autres
marathons relais mais souvent à quatre
concurrents et alors je crois que ces
dernières années les Kinen connais un
succès grandissant d'ailleurs avec ce
succès avec ce succès est-ce qu'il y a
des athlètes confirmés des produits
marathon qui qui viennent chez vous ah
oui mais dans tous les équidés à travers
la France puisque en Europe l'Ekiden
s'est développé à partir de 1992 donc ça
fait 20 ans
il y a de très belles performances pour
vous donner une idée quand même le
record d'Europe et détenu par les
Kenyans record du monde aussi en une
heure peut-être pour faire 42 km donc
pédaler un petit peu comme on dit dans
le jargon et juste sur ce fonctionnement
d'équipe j'aimerais revenir un petit peu
là dessus vous m'aviez déjà un peu
expliqué mais c'est un coureur fait 5 km
voilà alors passe le témoin c'est ça
l'équipe est très codifié par la
Fédération Française d'Athlétisme c'est
si relay 5 km 10 km 5 km 10 km et le
dernier relais 7 km 995 pour faire le
marathon et alors du coup ça veut dire
que un athlète pas trop confirmé un
jogger du dimanche peut s'inscrire à
l'équilaine sans problème
il arrive il donne son relais un copain
qui est un peu plus affûté qui s'est
entraîné deux fois dans la semaine voilà
et lui il peut faire le 10 km mais tout
le monde peut participer le marathon
c'est pas ma spécialité malheureusement
le dimanche c'est pas facile alors le
nôtre a une petite particularité c'est
que on ne respecte pas complètement la
règle de la FFA qui stipule que
relais doit se faire sur une boucle de 5
km et sur route nous on préfère
privilégier la boucle des 2 km 5 pour
avoir plus d'ambiance pour sa chambre un
petit peu c'est sympa on rigole bien et
puis en plus bon ça se passe sur la base
de loisirs où il y a un cadre vraiment
agréable c'est dans la nature on voit
des canards on voit des lapins parce que
même plus sympa que de la route du
Béthune et alors du coup on peut encore
s'inscrire ou pas on peut encore
inscrire jusqu'à vendredi mais là il
faut faire vite parce que
la première année nous avions 37 équipe
on en avait 47 la deuxième on avait 76
l'année dernière et c'est en limite à
100 parce qu'on veut qu'on voit une
progression
très importante parce que c'est le seul
dans la région qui est en train de se
développer mais on veut pouvoir
accueillir l'ensemble des coureurs dans
de bonnes conditions donc cette année on
a dit on se limite à 100 équipes puis
après c'est mixte parce que j'ai vu des
dames
il y a un challenge exclusivement
féminin donc il disait de 6 filles
il y a un challenge homme il y a un
challenge mixte ou alors là il faut
avoir trois hommes et trois filles qui
se relaient et puis un challenge dit de
club entreprise où on retrouve des
athlètes du SMAG de Lizzie d'Argentan
de bonne basket quand même très bien
merci beaucoup Francis pense d'être venu
sur le plateau de téléfil ce soir et on
se donne rendez-vous donc dimanche 23 à
quelle heure à 9h
Anthony
français
de sujet oui tout à fait Coupe de France
c'est du football retour de la Coupe de
France déjà même si la finale est
souvent enfin mai pour les clubs
amateurs comme trap notamment c'est déjà
c'est déjà revenu et malheureusement ce
week-endra pour rencontrer l'AC
Boulogne-Billancourt malheureusement
parce que le Petit Poucet n'a pas réussi
l'exploit tant esp érer en Coupe de
France et c'est incliné face à la
Boulogne-Billancourt allez on regarde
les images
il ne fallait pas être en retard au
stade Gilbert Champsac pour le troisième
tour de Coupe de France assez fou entre
trappes et là c'est Boulogne-Billancourt
première incursion des trappistes dans
le camp de la CBB et premier penalty
sifflé transformé dans la foulée dans le
petit filet que Y a froid la CBB
pensionnaire de division d'honneur ne
tarde pas à répondre sur ce coup franc
dévié au premier poteau par le capitaine
Lassana comté mais avant la mi-temps la
défense trappiste malgré une belle
résistance c'est d'une seconde fois sur
cette frappe enroulée du pied droit de
Maxime et Macron
allons-am du dernier quart d'heure trap
réduit le score à nouveau sur penalty
c'est alors que le match s'emballe non
pas un
non pas deux
mais quatre buts sont marqués dans les
dernières minutes de la rentrée on est
réduit à 10 la marche était trop haute
pour le club yvelin 5 à 3
malgré cette élimination il faut le dire
que attrape le championnat reste la
priorité ils sont promus ils sont
arrivés donc en promotion d'honneur
cette année je vous propose d'écouter
tout de suite l'entraîneur de trap Hervé
ducaux plutôt satisfait de ses joueurs
malgré cet élimination
parce que on n'est pas si je pense à
quelque chose de côté de quelque chose
de joli après 10 contre 11 contre une DH
qui joue la montée en CFA2 c'est c'est
quasiment mission impossible même si
méga ils ont tout donné à discontro 11
marqué trois buts contre une DH chapeau
canadien la priorité c'est le
championnat
donc on va s'appeler à ça pour pour
aller jouer à Saint-Cloud dimanche voilà
donc il faut pas se tromper d'objectif
on continuera à suivre les exploits de
Trappes on verra bon là ils ont été
battus mais c'était logique et puis ça
fait ça fait un bon entraînement en tout
cas d'avoir une équipe de jouer une
équipe supérieure ça fait un bon